[Music]
you are watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive in the next half hour
we'll see what's making the headlines
with the journalist and author christina
patterson and the broadcaster and former
advisor to boris johnson at culver
ranger there they both are so let's see
what's on some of those front pages for
you now
don't panic the observer leads with the
business secretary quesy quarten bid to
calm fears over gas price increases
the sunday express says boris johnson
will launch a new charm offensive on
america this week as he flies out to new
york to make his u.n speech
diplomacy is on the front of the
telegraph ii with new foreign secretary
liz trust defending the security pact
between the uk us and australia in the
face of french anger
the times reports on what it calls an
unprecedented intervention from the
speaker of the commons after a female mp
pulled out of the labour annual
conference following online threats
travel unlocks four holidays at half
term that's on the front of the eye
double jabbed arrivals set to no longer
need expensive pcr tests
the mirror has the news that ex-england
rugby legend rob burrow will receive a
new wonder drug to fight his
motor-neurone disease
so we're joined tonight by christina
patterson and cool beer ranger good
evening to you both um let's start with
the observer front page and looking at
the story that obviously we've been
covering this evening um and that is the
energy and potential crisis the headline
there don't panic minister bids to calm
fears over gas prices uh christina take
us into this first
yes well when a minister
don't panic it doesn't exactly calm one
down um
prices are absolutely rocket at the
moment and it's not
uh it's not entirely clear why there
have been suggestions in the telegraph
actually that putin might be involved in
um helping to manipulate push
push prices sky high as a way of
destabilizing these stabilizing us
if that's correct not but the
consequences are very simple
food shortages shortages of carbon
dioxide which although we're trying to
get rid of it on every other front we do
need for frozen food for meat production
for
uh food production in all kinds of ways
so this really could lead not just to
massive hikes and bills for consumers
but also for food shortages on top of
the food shortage we already have
through shortage of holier drivers so
this could be a very consideration
uh is the minister do you feel um calmed
by the the don't panic uh instruction
well it seems to be the what he's saying
and uh quasi-quatern is quite a talented
minister he's been uh
seen as a rising star uh for a long time
in the conservative party but i think
the other thing the government's
probably trying to do is avoid acting
too late in something so we all saw what
happened with the original or the
original start of the pandemic and it
felt like you know we weren't sure what
we were doing here potentially the
government can see problems emerging
we've obviously seen issues around gas
supplies a number have already gone bust
with the
hugely increasing cost of gas
it's a complicated issue because it's
not just about supplies international
routes
as christina says there's a
rumor who knows conjecture about russian
supply there's european supply chains
that we need to understand and then
there's the actual impact on industry
and complicated supply chains that get
impacted by the price of gas and the
distribution of it so a massive concern
the minister quite rightly tried to calm
nerves but it has been said that he will
be undertaking further meetings tomorrow
and on monday i think tomorrow with off
gem uh circling back with the suppliers
uh the energy providers on monday as
well so obviously taking it very
seriously uh trying to understand the
landscape and the size and the impact of
the potential issue uh christina does it
seem as though we're on the verge of a
disaster eight hours
of talks today also further talks
tomorrow um and it seems that you know
according to the the observer there um
that this will be thrashed out in in
further hours of of discussions and and
the the aim really is to prevent
millions falling into fuel poverty
well i i can't say that i feel hugely
reassured by quasi-contact writing's
words i mean i'm old enough to remember
in the 70s doing my homework by
candlelight and the three-day week and
my father having to sleep on his office
floor in pajamas um you know i i know
that things people often find it hard to
imagine that things can get that bad but
they can get that bad and we've already
got uh you know sort of echoes of the
1970s and quite a lot that's going on at
the moment so i think when a minister is
spending eight hours on a saturday
having meetings and is likely to do the
same on a sunday
i can't say it instills confidence in me
cool though move us on to the telegraph
and um this story but the french are
very very um
annoyed uh trustifies eu with vow to
fight for freedom and france warning
that the new defense deal will have
repercussions for the future of nato and
this seems incredibly serious
well it does for the french but it seems
like a bit of a coup for
uh the uk the us
and australia an alliance bringing
together capability securities and uh
contracts uh worth significant money to
the us and the uk and jobs now you can
understand if the french have been uh
let's say nobled in a business deal here
they are they have their nose out of
join and have demonstrated that by
withdrawing their ambassadors from
canberra and washington but
you know this is geopolitical uh it's
also industrial um there's been a
alliance between uh three uh countries
here and they're looking to share
security going forward now
maybe the french have been outmaneuvered
here and it feels that's what's happened
and so they're not best pleased but who
would blame them
yes the the french have described it as
unacceptable behavior
um would you agree with that christina
or is this just
good business sense
well i think the french have the french
ambassador has accused us of opportunism
and duplicity and
liz trust of course never known for
underselling herself
um or what she calls global britain
having of course been a very ardent
remainer turned uh born again brexiter
and now born again global britainer
whatever that might be
is um talking it up as this great coup
and talking about us fighting for
freedom and promoting freedom worldwide
and wanting to plant the flag for global
britain on the world stage which is in a
rather excuse excruciating uh analogy
but the thing is um it's already
apparently emerged that president xi
jinping is now extremely unlikely to
come to cop 26
because so fed up with this thing which
is you know fairly understandable so i
think when liz trust described herself
in bbc interview a few years ago as no
diplomat she may well have been speaking
nothing less than the truth because to
have managed to upset both france and
china in one fell swoop shortly before
you're about to host one of the most
important summits possibly in world
history i mean certainly very important
because
i think
anybody but a nut case now would
acknowledge we do have a climate
emergency this doesn't look terribly
sensible to me
cover according to the express the prime
minister boris johnson is uh bidding to
level up the world what do we understand
by that statement
well i i think people are still trying
to work out what it means for the uk
which is why we've seen uh the new
government department michael goves
heading up uh including leveling up in
his agenda but i think living out the
world
i think this is what we're talking about
in terms of sustainability and really
the mega challenges that there are about
helping those nations uh that need more
support to be able to do the things they
can do to reduce their carbon footprint
while also the nations that can't afford
it making the right decisions locally
and boris johnson this government
as christie says holding cop 26 in
november want to get that point across
and i think it's a point that everyone
wants to lean in on but it's about
tangible differences what can be done to
help all those countries that need
support from the richer countries that
are probably further ahead on this
agenda
i think the key thing here though just
going back to the china point is that
china are already struggling uh to make
uh to square the circle in terms of co2
emissions we all know that they're uh
not quite hitting the mark in terms of
their power stations their their
requirement for travel for material for
production for use of coal and it's very
hard for them so they'll be looking for
a reason uh potentially this reason
around uh the trade deal and the
security issue
around uh um
australia but i don't think that should
be distracting from what we're trying to
do and this government is trying to do
and what all of us hope they will do
which is really progress the agenda
around sustainability at cop26 uh
christina the the express uh describing
it as a charm offensive by the prime
minister on america
well i feel very very i feel very sorry
for those people who are going to be
subject subjected to this charm
offensive but i just had to laugh at
this headline because this is boris
johnson in true world king mode we all
know that as a child he decided he
wanted to be wanted to be world king
which of course is why unfortunately for
us he has ended up as a prime minister
but the idea i mean nobody ever knew
what leveling up meant it was a
ridiculous slogan and now of course all
kinds of people the most the latest
being andy haldane formerly bank of
england are being drafted in to kind of
turn this ridiculous slogan into some
kind of reality but if they really
wanted to level up the world what they
should do is give away the enormous
number of excess vaccines that we have
been accumulating because if we don't do
that then we are going to end up a with
you know a pandemic that goes on for a
very long time a new variance but also
there is nothing that is going to
exacerbate the inequality in the world
more than having the western world with
you know through endless vaccines we're
about to guess our third
third vaccine those of us who are over
50 and the rest of the world mostly
having none so you know he wants to
level up that's how you can do it uh
just got time uh cool to talk about the
i front page and this is about you know
the travel situation moving towards uh
normality not quite there yet but
certainly easing up for for many people
particularly with the half term holidays
coming up
well it looks like the change in uh the
uh traffic light system so it's just
gone to red or uh you can go and a
number of countries coming off the red
list and also the simplification around
test julian you know it has been
challenging i personally traveled
abroad this week and realized you know
taking that test to come back if it had
come positive uh you know you have a
challenge you can't come back now that's
been removed if you're double vaccinated
it did need simplification uh i hope it
really helps the travel industry in the
run up to half term in october when
people seem to be booking
it still will there still be need to be
precautions but i think the big message
to everybody is get vaccinated you know
if you can get those uh get the double
vaccination done and really let's uh
let's make sure we can get some some
kind of enjoyment and some kind of
holidays still this year okay cool
vancouver thank you very much for the
moment we are going to take a break but
coming up
gove in cabinet power grab the telegraph
reports on the reshuffles biggest winner
stay with us
[Music]
luluset is an inuit name for the place
of big icebergs and certainly that was
the case
the reason why i went to do it was very
very simple i swim in some of the most
vulnerable ecosystems in the world to
highlight what's happening there
uh in a lulla set now it's the fastest
moving glacier in the world it's now
moving at a speed of 40 meters per day
in summer and so this was a swim in the
month now before the big climate change
negotiations which take place in glasgow
to highlight the speed and the scale of
the climate crisis
i
spent nearly 18 years swimming in the
polar regions so there's a lot of
experience that goes into it before i
get into the water i get slowly into the
water so that i don't hyperventilate and
then i swim as fast as i can but it's
been years and years of experience and
years and years of acclimatization to be
able to get into these freezing cold
waters
when i do the swim so this swim was a
multi-day swim
it was 12 swims
apologies 14 swims over a period of 12
days
uh i swim in the morning i then have to
rewarm i then swim in the afternoon so
it really was unrelenting though by far
the hardest swim i have ever undertaken
in my life the glacier is at the top of
a long fjord the field is about 60
kilometers long and at the mouth of the
field there are a number of huge
icebergs these icebergs are about a
kilometer tall it's unbelievable
and during the swim one of these
dislodged and behind it were literally
thousands and thousands and thousands of
smaller icebergs and i've never seen
anything like it because it was like a
motorway of ice ice coming off the
greenland ice sheet down the glacier
into the field and then
it was like as i say a motorway of ice
going all the way out 10 kilometers out
to sea
i mean ice is essential for life on
earth
i say to people no ice
no life it's essential for life on earth
because ice keeps our planet within a
temperature range in which we can live
and so now as the arctic is beginning to
melt and down in the southern hemisphere
as antarctica is also
melting and also the glaciers on the
high mountains of the world
this has a huge impact on us all over
the world so what's happening now in a
lulla set
will literally impact every single
person on this planet every future
generation and the whole of the animal
kingdom
[Music]
[Music]
it was my vision to come and protect
regulation in future
[Music]
animals like lion can enter into bombas
they kill their livestocks and this
leads to human wildlife country
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview still with me christina
patterson and cool the ranger welcome
back to both of you let's have a look at
the um telegraph um which seems to be
saying that that michael gove has um
come out on tops in the cabinet with
shuffle and perhaps um fed the best of
all
colby
how long have we been doing this zoom
thing now colby
my apologies it still happens i'm sorry
i'm joking go ahead
no it's it seems michael gove has found
the unmute button for well and truly and
also uh extended his volume in
government let me put it that way uh at
the new uh department that he has well
not new but added responsibility as well
with the leveling up element of this
government's agenda being added to it
now why is that important why is it
something important in the title of a
department because it focuses the minds
it focuses civil servants priorities it
tells them quite clearly where this
government that governor michael goes
focusing but the other side about
leveling up is it is a broad agenda it
does spread across a number of
departments because what this government
is trying to do based on the election
that it won and all those votes it got
from
the red wall seats is deliver
infrastructure housing and better
services across different parts of the
country that didn't feel that they were
being recognized
and receiving what they felt their fair
share leveling up so if a department now
has that name and michael gove has that
challenge not only does he have the
department but he seems to have
authority across many other areas of
government so yes sounds like a win for
mr gove christina if the department is
named as such a leveling up does that
mean it's going to be more effective
i mean it sounds orwellian to me i mean
whether they get to take all these
peculiar slogans and nobody has a clue
what any of them means and you know put
them in sort of neon lights over all
kind of government departments and
demand that people stop using ordinary
english and start using these peculiar
slogans i have absolutely no idea what
leveling up means i mean in in in terms
of english language is absolutely
nonsensical of course we know that boris
johnson wants to keep his red wool seeds
and you know that's a pragmatic thing
but in terms of what it actually means
who knows i don't think i don't think
michael gove knows boris johnson doesn't
know what what michael gove does need to
do is make sure that more houses are
built and that is a serious challenge
because obviously uh you know in order
to build more houses you have to build
in people's backyards and then lots of
people you don't like stuff being built
in their backyards and as we saw from um
the recent i think it was the amisham
by-election which um
uh went to the lib dems you know people
get really angry about this stuff so it
is a it's a very difficult challenge
that michael gove has been set he is
among the more competent
members of the cabinet um i think
matthew paris yesterday described the
new cabinet as a cabinet of charlatans
for a government of charlatans and i'd
have to say i agree with that assessment
but i do think that michael gove is
competent and whether one likes him is
another issue but he probably has as
good a chance as anyone of of turning
leveling up into something beyond a
slogan and i would be fascinated to see
what it actually means corvair out of
interest would you attempted a
definition a succinct definition of
leveling up for us
well i'll do my best but i think
leveling up is all about evening out
investment across the country whether
that be housing transport public
services
that's what this government is trying to
do and that's why it's a lot to do with
infrastructure and as christina said uh
housing
we do need to build and invest the right
transport links and housing for people
in part this country that just haven't
seen enough of it over decades well done
i don't know if christine is satisfied
or not but
we'll move on to just got time for the
uh matt cartoon at the sunday telegraph
um talk us into this is quite funny uh
the the actual script says the the texas
let's see how the eco fanatics like this
i've super glued myself to a recycling
bin uh you can see the cartoon up there
christina
well i thought well i mean i love matt
cartoon but i i mean i think if you were
on the m25 it's no joke but the idea of
bringing disruption to uh one of the
roads in the uk that has more traffic
than pretty much any other anyone who's
ever been near the m25 knows that the
last thing it needs is protest and
disruption so i think if anything is
going to put people off um any kind of
response to climate change they are this
would be it and they're doing an
excellent job you know alienating the
entire country so well done